this is star
[Music]
talk so let's move on to Joe gwa uh or
gor so he's coming from Facebook and he
says he goes hey
Bill don't forget the dioxins better
address this one bill uh yeah so daxon
was uh another I put that tone in there
myself yeah but I I think you're in the
spirit of his uh inquiry his query uh
the uh dioxins were another chemical
used I guess as a pesticide that turned
out to have really troubling
consequences okay and so they've been
curtailed stopped but I've met people in
the Biotech Industry in the seed
business who think DDT is a was a great
thing because it because it did the job
well suppressed mosquitoes and that
suppressed malaria but I'm not sure DDT
is what we all want to be drinking and
so Dio was even more uh aggressive as a
medical problem and so it's been
curtailed just that these companies used
to
make uh deadly uh herbicides used in
Warfare asent orange well they they were
hired to do that and they're not doing
it anymore I don't know how responsible
we should hold them however we should
learn from the past like don't don't
just make stuff that's amazingly deadly
and spread it all over the place on
another country and take no
responsibility for it you know that
sounds like a good policy but this once
again Chuck demands
that that evil word that is troubling to
so many people nowadays
regulation where we'd all get together
and decide what's fair and make people
stick to it Regulators Mount up okay
well in moderation so uh in general this
is a solvable problem far the seed
companies are in business to sell seeds
to Farmers and Farmers want to buy seeds
that they want to buy and so the market
takes care of it however having
companies make pesticides or herbicides
which have bad consequences you can
regulate that I think what happens is in
the mind of the
consumer is you have a company like
Monsanto who makes the seeds they
genetically modify the seeds they modify
the plants that create the seeds they
modify the plants that create the seeds
and then they plant those seeds then
they make the food and they also put the
food on the shelf and I think this is
where a great deal of Suspicion stems
from vertically integrated it's
vertically integrated that makes you
that makes you scary you know that that
that's that's scared yeah scared well
yes you are frighten I'm frightened
sitting here is very
troubling I I know what you meant though
okay it's another adjective related the
same root I got you but root pun
intended when it comes to agriculture so
the the deal is Farmers make choices
they can do business with Pioneer or
Monsanto or whatever and uh you can buy
food from this guy or that guy but I
know what you mean it's troubling when
you feel like you're out of control
right because the whole process from
stem to STM seems to be that this is why
uh the non-GMO movement has a place okay
we'll see if that's economically
competitive like and you can say
corporations are squashing them I don't
think so I think you'll find that
organic farming takes more input than uh
than uh farming with genetically
modified crops and so we'll let the
marketplace sort that out I mean people
make jokes about a certain business they
call it whole
paycheck right because the food is so
expensive that's right grown small
quantities with high input so we'll see
what happens in the marketplace all
right this is Star
[Music]
Talk